big data is not an unmitigated good like
many things in society in fact probably
all things it comes with risks as well
and it comes with a dark side and one
dark side of course is privacy that
exists today it'll exist tomorrow maybe
it gets bigger with big data as well but
there is something else to play for
something else that's a little bit more
troubling still and that is if you will
propensity it is big data algorithms
making a prediction of what you are
likely to do before you've actually done
it now the criminal justice system has
never really dealt with this sort of
problem before typically you have to
commit a crime before you are penalized
for that crime but what if it is simply
a prediction that you have a likelihood
of committing a crime would society be
remiss not to intervene if I could tell
with a 98% statistical accuracy that you
are likely to shoplift in the next 12
months
Public Safety requires that I interact
and maybe I don't put you into jail it's
not Minority Report it's not pre-crime I
have a social worker knock on your door
and say we'd like to help you we'd like
to get you an after-school job if you're
a teenager we like to sort of support
you well that sounds like it's a benefit
but in reality if you think about it
this person was going to be stigmatized
in the eye of his peers school teachers
parents in fact he'll probably feel
stigmatized in his own eyes and feel
badly and we might even encourage the
torts sort of behavior that we want to
prevent the point is that he will have
been a victim of a prediction about him
and he could rightly say I will be the
2% that will not shoplift that I'll
exercise my moral choice so the solution
seems to be in a big data world we want
to somehow sanctify the notion of the
human volition of human free will and to
preserve that as a central attribute
you